congratulations your show love is a hit
people love the program okay I'm just
curious how you're handling the success
aspect of all of this oh it's a little
different now it is a little different I
do really love being a rising star that
feels like it makes sense that's great
but there are certain parts of it that I
am uncomfortable with for example
occasionally you have to go and get your
photo taken on a red carpet which seems
very glamorous and fun but in reality
it's a terrifying nightmare people don't
know that it's weird to stand there when
they're all taking pictures it's not it
doesn't feel like a glamorous event it
feels highly unnatural and when you take
a photo normally you smile also most
people figure out their photo face right
but I haven't done that and it shows in
my red carpet photos yeah we found a red
carpet photo of you with a Misha there
area and here you are what your face
they're nice I do look like I have a
fever and also that I'm drunk yes
most people don't smile and I went to
that premiere for Amy's movie snatched
and I asked my friends who had full hair
and makeup and I had just sort of tied
my hair up at home as I can be smiling
are we smiling and they were like
absolutely not and then they did like
sexy looks and I tried to mimic it and
that's what I look like yeah yeah I
don't like doing red carpet okay I can
help you what should I do
Oh what no I I'm the last person I just
give I mean I don't even I do this and I
try not to do anything else
I like to do this here but whenever I I
try to avoid events where I have to
stand on a carpet and and go like that
because I I feel like a complete I just
it feels weird it doesn't feel right a
fraud thank you hey Diaz Froy
a hideous winter bone fraud yeah
you